along with the animated return of four
turtles were also teenagers who are also
mutants and were also ninjas we bring
you the conclusion of a real-time
Thriller miniseries the return of yet
another great Taiko ytt project the
return of a Netflix coming-of-age
dramedy and one Mega freaking scary
movie about why you should never go into
the ocean it's all here to take a bite
out of your viewing calendar on this
week's what to watch
[Music]
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rat heading
from the sewer straight into theaters is
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Mutant
Mayhem yes the tmnts have been around
since the late 80s but this is a brand
new iteration of the classic material
bringing its own artistic style kinda
looks like a comic book come to life
along with a fresh voice cast and news
story details you could call it a reboot
I'll call it the first reason to check
this one out the second is that while
The Supporting Cast will be very
recognizable to your ear which we'll get
to in a second the four main Turtles are
voiced by relatively unknown actors in
an effort to cast actual teenagers plus
the foursome recorded much of their
dialogue together to encourage
improvisation and form better chemistry
but what I want to know is that they
record in the sewers below New York City
let's hope not and remember that big
name Supporting Cast I mentioned well
it's the third reason to join in in this
Mayhem because it includes Ice Cube as
the main villain Superfly Jackie Chan as
Master Splinter Iowa debris from the
bear as April O'Neil and if you want
more how about Giancarlo Esposito John
Cena post Malone Paul Rudd and Rose
Byrne and if that is kind of sounding
like a Seth Rogen movie well it is he's
a producer co-writer and the voice of a
villain
operation has commenced phones tablets
blind is under control
for your TVs this week is the thrilling
finale of hijack on Apple TV plus this
seven part miniseries Stars Idris Elba
and that's the main reason to watch this
one he's the man that's it that's the
reason he stars as a corporate business
negotiator who has to use his skills to
try and stop a hijacking on a seven-hour
flight haven't we all and if the word
seven part and seven hour caught your
ear that's because this one happens in
real time much like another hit Thriller
series 24 which is a second good reason
to catch this series the final reason is
that it's certified fresh at 86 on the
Tomato Meter with the critics consensus
that says largely devoid of Storytelling
turbulence and benefiting greatly from
its real-time pacing hijack is a glossy
but effective Thriller that achieves
genuine liftoff hey hey easy on the puns
there critics that's our job
half the healing is often found an
opportunity to help others what does
that mean you're on trash Duty maybe
next time you'll think twice about
running away and not telling anybody why
am I here I didn't even go to California
another show that's definitely worth
your time this week is the third season
premiere of reservation dogs the first
reason to visit this series is that it
was created by taika waititi and
Sterling harjo it follows the lives of
four indigenous teenagers in rural
Oklahoma with story lines inspired by
events from harjoe's childhood the
series features all indigenous writers
and directors along with an almost
entirely indigenous American cast and
production team which was a major Focus
during the development process and
another good reason to check it out plus
not only are seasons one and two
certified fresh but they're at a hundred
percent and 98 on the Tomato Meter
respectively
oh
hi hi
also still pumping in the world of TV is
a Netflix series Heart Stopper back with
season two a good reason to check out
this coming of age romantic dramedies
that it was created and written by Alice
oseman and based on her webcomic and
graphic novel of the same name it tells
the story of a gay school boy who falls
in love with a classmate and Not only
was season one a major hit with critics
sitting at a hundred percent certified
fresh on the Tomato Meter but the
audience score is a whopping 96 percent
too people love it on top of that Heart
Stopper was one of the top English
series on Netflix within a couple of
days of its release increasing the
popularity of not only the graphic novel
based on but also many of the songs used
in the series as well how cool is that
and for good measure the series earned
nine nominations and five wins at the
inaugural children's and family Emmy
Awards
the biggest snake I've ever seen
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
that's the apex predator
everybody make it to the stations and
finally if you're willing to jump back
into theaters beware in a good way of
Meg to the trench the previous film in
the series The Meg may be lacking a
fresh score on the Tomato Meter but what
it didn't lack was the ability to draw a
large crowds pulling in over 530 million
dollars at the worldwide box office and
Paving the way for a sequel that's a
large sum and a great reason to see this
one and good news for fans of the first
because it starred Jason Statham is back
and if Statham's return is its own
reason to see this one then so is the
return of not only more Megs AKA
Megalodon sharks but this time they'll
encounter other giant prehistoric sea
creatures as well dude what plus behind
the scenes director Benjamin Wheatley
brings a great combo of skills for this
movie having worked on psychological
thrillers plus the adaptation high-rise
with Tom Hiddleston and the action
comedy free fire with Brie Larson AKA
dude is qualified
okay we did it five picks to help you
forget about all the terrifying things
lurking in our oceans and sewers be sure
to let us and your fellow viewers know
in the comments what you did check out
whether it was on this list or not
remember to check out rottentomatoes.com
for the latest updates on scores and
reviews for everything mentioned as well
as the movie and TV World At Large and
please check out our rt25 page at
rottentomatoes.com so you can vote in
our fan fave movie and TV poll we'll
give you an imaginary sticker I said
this last week guys come on that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay fresh
[Music]
foreign